168 years before Game of Thrones, the Targaryens
were at their peak in Westeros.
There were many Targaryens and even more dragons.
From the perspective of every house in the
Seven Kingdoms (major or minor) as well as
from the perspective of commoners and even
from the perspective of the Targaryens themselves,
the Targaryen rule seemed to be so powerful
that even 1000 years from then on, they would
still rule the continent, but then the Dance
of the Dragons happened.
It was a Targaryen civil war that saw the
end of many Targaryens and most of their dragons.
It nearly destroyed their entire house.
This is one of the most exciting and most
epic events that ever happened in the history
of this world and it’s exactly the event
that House of the Dragon will follow.
Therefore it shouldn’t come as a surprise
that many main characters of the show are
going to be the dragon-lord ancestors of Daenerys
Targaryen and Jon Snow.
The series is based on George R.R. Martin’s
book Fire And Blood which covers the entire
Targaryen history in Westeros, starting from
Aegon Targaryen and his conquest, and going
to the Dance of the Dragons while Fire And
Blood part 2 will also cover the Blackfyre
Rebellions and will end with Robert’s Rebellion.
The prequel series House of the Dragon finds
the Targaryen dynasty at the absolute apex
of its power, with around 20 dragons flying
over King’s Landing and Dragonstone.
Most empires—real and imagined—crumble
from such heights.
In the case of the Targaryens, their slow
fall begins almost 192 years before the events
of Game of Thrones, when King Viserys Targaryen
breaks with a century of tradition by naming
his daughter Rhaenyra heir to the Iron Throne.
But when Viserys later fathers a son, the
court is shocked that Rhaenyra retains her
status as his heir, and seeds of division
sow friction across the realm.
So, basically, the show starts with King Viserys
I Targaryen sitting on the Iron Throne with
Rhaenyra, his oldest child, being his heir
instead of his son Aegon, much to displeasure
of Aegon’s mother Queen Alicent Hightower.
Through a series of flashbacks, we will learn
about why King Viserys chose to keep Rhaenyra
as his designated heir even when he got a
son.
We’ll also learn about the tension in the
King’s Landing court between Rhaenyra’s
faction and Alicent’s faction, or in the
other words, between the Blacks and the Greens.
Rhaenyra’s faction obviously supports Rhaenyra
while Alicent’s faction supports Aegon as
the future ruler of Westeros.
King Viserys I Targaryen had three children
by his first queen, Aemma Arryn, but only
one, Princess Rhaenyra, survived to adulthood.
Lacking a son to succeed him, Viserys began
to train Rhaenyra to be his heir.
Young Rhaenyra was included in discussions
of the affairs of the state and was allowed
to participate in meetings of the small council.
Many of the nobles took note, and Rhaenyra
soon acquired a huge number of supporters.
After the passing of Queen Aemma, Viserys
named Rhaenyra his heir, and hundreds of lords
and landed knights paid obeisance to her.
The king later remarried to Alicent Hightower
and had four more children: Aegon, Helaena,
Aemond, and Daeron.
A great tourney was held at King's Landing
on the fifth anniversary of Viserys's marriage
to Alicent.
During the opening feast, Queen Alicent wore
a green gown, while Princess Rhaenyra dressed
in the red and black of House Targaryen.
Note was taken, and thereafter it became the
custom to refer to "greens" and "blacks" when
talking of the queen's party and the party
of the princess, respectively.
While many expected that the King would change
the succession order and the Hightowers tried
to persuade him to do so many times, Viserys
only strengthened Rhaenyra's place in the
succession by marrying her to Ser Laenor Velaryon
- who himself had Targaryen blood through
his mother, Princess Rhaenys.
It’s not a big spoiler as his character
is not that important, but in season 1 Laenor
will be executed (but I won’t tell you by
who although you will probably figure it out)
and after Rhaenyra’s husband gets executed,
Rhaenyra will marry her uncle, Prince Daemon
Targaryen, younger brother to Viserys.
This only strengthens her position even more
as Daemon himself has a lot of supporters
and is arguably the best warrior, commander,
and general of this time.
In season 1 it will also be established that
Alicent’s and Rhaenyra’s children have
hatred towards each other, which will lead
to many horrible events by the time the war
breaks out.
Speaking of the war breaking out, things start
to escalate towards the end of season 1.
King Viserys dies, Queen Alicent Hightower
conceals Viserys's death from the public and
instead has Ser Criston Cole, Lord Commander
of the Kingsguard, summon the small council
to Alicent's apartments in Maegor's Holdfast.
Grand Maester Orwyle here predicts a war,
believing that Rhaenya would never be willing
to give up her birthright, and had dragons
at her disposal.
When Lyman declares that he was not willing
to listen to people plotting to steal Rhaenyra’s
crown and attempts to leave, Ser Criston kills
him.
This makes Lyman the first casualty of the
Dance of the Dragons.
After Lyman's death, the green council made
their plans, vowing their loyalty to their
new king, and arresting all those in King's
Landing who could be loyal to Rhaenyra.
To all those who might be loyal to Aegon,
ravens are sent.
Prince Aemond (Aegon’s brother) is sent
to Storm's End to betroth himself to one of
Lord Borros Baratheon's daughters, so House
Baratheon might fight for Aegon II.
Meanwhile, Rhaenyra remains on Dragonstone,
unaware of what happened instead of coming
to King’s Landing to claim the throne.
Criston who once served Rhaenyra, convinced
Viserys's son, Prince Aegon the Elder, to
claim the rule of the Seven Kingdoms as his
father lay dead.
For this, he became known as Criston the Kingmaker.
Viserys had decreed his heir to be Rhaenyra
Targaryen, Princess of Dragonstone, the daughter
from his first wife, Aemma Arryn.
The greens at the Red Keep support Aegon the
Elder, the eldest son of his second wife Alicent,
however, and Criston takes into custody any
blacks remaining at court.
Alicent forbids septons and silent sisters
from treating Viserys's body.
A week after Viserys's death, his passing
is finally publicly revealed with the greens
accounting the accession of Aegon II Targaryen.
The silent sisters then prepare the late king's
body for the traditional burning of a Targaryen.
Aegon's coronation is hastily prepared.
The Dragonpit is chosen as the site for its
towering bronze doors, strong roof, and thick
walls making it easily defensible.
Ser Criston Cole crowns Aegon, while Alicent
Hightower crowns Aegon's sister-wife, Helaena.
However, the night before, the first defection
had taken place.
Ser Steffon Darklyn of the Kingsguard had
left the city, with, amongst other things,
the crown worn by kings, Jaehaerys I and Viserys
I and is taking it to the rightful Queen Rhaenyra.
At Dragonstone, Rhaenyra finds out that her
father died and Aegon staged a coup and was
crowned King in King’s Landing.
Furious, Rhaenyra quickly made her own council
at Dragonstone, the black council.
The participants are, amongst others, her
uncle-husband Daemon, her three eldest sons
Jacaerys, Lucerys, and Joffrey, Lord Corlys
Velaryon, and his wife, Princess Rhaenys.
Rhaenyra is crowned queen, using the crown
her father and great-grandfather had worn,
thanks to Ser Steffon Darklyn, who had arrived
from King's Landing.
Prince Daemon places the crown on Rhaenyra's
head himself and is named the Protector of
the Realm, and Jacaerys is officially named
Prince of Dragonstone and heir to the Iron
Throne.
During the council it’s resolved that while
Rhaenyra remains at Dragonstone to regain
her health, Prince Daemon and Caraxes would
travel to the Riverlands, to make Harrenhal
their base and rallying point for those loyal
to Rhaenyra.
House Velaryon would close off the Gullet
blocking all shipping from Blackwater Bay.
Princess Rhaenys is convinced that Storm's
End would declare for Rhaenyra, since Lord
Boremund Baratheon, the deceased father of
Lord Borros and Rhaenys's uncle, had always
been a supporter of Rhaenys.
Prince Daemon is also convinced that Lady
Jeyne Arryn, the Maiden of the Vale, would
bring her support to their side as Rhaenyra’s
mother was Arryn herself.
Although they believe the North to be too
remote to play an important part in the war,
messages are to be sent to those lords nevertheless,
with the eldest Jacaerys visiting the Arryns
of the Eyrie, the Manderlys of White Harbor,
and the Starks of Winterfell.
Rhaenyra's second son, Lucerys, travels to
Storm's End.
Rhaenyra proclaims King Aegon and his mother
Queen Alicent as well as all their supporters
– traitors and enemy of house Targaryen.
Back at King's Landing, at this point already
a King, Aegon proclaims Rhaenyra traitor and
the enemy of House Targaryen, and thus the
Targaryen civil war starts.
Dragons will dance, swords will clash, monarchs
will rise and fall, and season 1 will end,
leaving you to impatiently wait for season
2 to see what happens next.
Basically, The House of the Dragon is focused
on the war of succession between Aegon II
and his half-sister Rhaenyra over their father
Viserys I's throne, the war that will be fought
from 129 AC to 131 AC.
It will see the deaths of monarchs, the deaths
of Targaryens and their dragons as well as
major battles across the Seven Kingdoms with
the Starks and the Velaryons fighting the
hardest on Rhaenryra’s side and the Lannisters
and Baratheons fighting the hardest on Aegon’s
side.
All of this and more you will see in 2022
on HBO.
Thank you so much for watching, if you enjoyed
this video please give it a big thumbs up
and I hope to see you in the next one, peace!